los australianos vuelven al encierro las
autoridades anunciaron un sexto
confinamiento en la ciudad de melbourne
rápida propagación de la variante de
venta del virus obligó a entrar en una
nueva ola de restricciones
empieza a tener la impresión que esto
nos golpea más fuerte hoy que cualquier
otro confinamiento en 9 está mi familia
desde hace mucho tiempo
en sydney se registró un récord de casos
por segundo día consecutivo a pesar de
retomar las restricciones el primer
ministro australiano aseguró que el país
avanza positivamente con su plan de
vacunación y descartó la vacuna
obligatoria el programa de vacunación en
australia ciertamente ya ha logrado
avanzar los desafíos que hemos tenido
los hemos superado ahora y las tasas de
vacunación que estamos logrando
coinciden con las que ya se han logrado
en muchos países del mundo creando wolf
mientras tanto en filipinas la capital
entró en un tercer bloqueo en un intento
por contener la propagación de la
variante delta se instalaron puestos de
control en las calles de manila y el
gobierno restringió los viajes de
entrada y salida de la ciudad
entramos de nuevo a una cuarentena
comunitaria y sólo unas pocas personas
pueden salir hay 158 conductores de
triciclos aquí ahora como vamos a
obtener ingresos con esta situación
brutal en tokio las autoridades
anunciaron un récord de casos de hoy 19
con más de 5 mil infecciones diarias así
que el gobierno extendió las
restricciones en 8 departamentos
más antes del final de los juegos
olímpicos y en tailandia las morgues
atestadas de víctimas de coronavirus han
tenido que alquilar contenedores
refrigerados para almacenar los cuerpos